and we just hit the moment where neither
one of us want to go take a number one
and touch our you-know-what because we
will now know why it would be burning
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by matthew mcconaughey
he's an academy award-winning actor you
know from films like magic mike dallas
buyers club interstellar and countless
others
his latest project however is a memoir
titled green lights which is set to
release on october 20th
matthew mcconaughey welcome to the show
hey good to be here sean i'm hungry too
well speaking of hungry i saw that
jalapeno loaded cheeseburger that you
made with aaron franklin
earlier this year so i take it you're a
guy who likes the spicy food
i do like spicy food i mean look been
able to travel around the world pick out
different spices all over
um i'm not the guy that chases down the
ghost pepper
to just see how much i can tolerate
which might be what i'm going to be
doing here in the next hour
but um i do i do like a little kick
to to my food
[Music]
classic garlic fresh
easy on out
[Music]
garlic up front
not too spicy comes on the second gear
let you know it's got a little hit to it
[Music]
so i want to start by talking about your
upcoming book green lights which you
describe
as a love letter to life chalk full of
stories and memories from keeping a
diary for over 36 years
and you really went full henry thoreau
at walden pond to write it
holding yourself up in the desert for 52
days with no electricity
do you typically seek out that level of
solitude when you're writing
i'm pretty fond of taking backpack trips
on my own to places where nobody knows
my name and they don't speak the
language for
22 days or less or more um
so that's a form of solitary confinement
you go someplace where nobody knows your
name and they don't speak the language
um so to write this
i've been daring myself to open that
treasure chest of diaries and actually
go see what the hell it all was
if i could make a book out of it for
years and finally i got a little time
off
that treasure chest diary started
barking at me going
come on mcconaughey dare you dare you
about the same time my wife goes you
know what you got to do get the hell out
of here
pack everything up so i packed up my
food my water my booze and i
loaded all my diaries in and went out to
a cabin in the middle of the desert
what happened in those diaries where
they fell into seven categories they
were stories
people places poems prayers pre-scribes
and a whole lot of bump stickers and so
i was like okay here's my seven kyle
there's my eight columns um
and then i went back home checked in on
my honeydews did my work caught up and
then
popped out for another 12 days so i did
it five different times
for about 10 to 12 days a piece
this is a very good looking label by the
way dawson's that's actually sweeter
than the first one
oh that's that's a winner already i'm
gonna move that out front a little bit
dawson that's real good so in 2019 you
were minted as the minister of culture
at your alma mater the university of
texas which as i understand it is a
position that kind of
oversees the intersection of tradition
sports and commerce within the athletic
department
when you took that position what were
some of the specific changes that you
thought needed to happen in order to
define a culture within that
capitalistic
ecosystem of major college sports yeah
so
within the university it started off me
saying look
the same values that create a
championship team on the field
are the same values that can create a
champion in the classroom that can go
off and do good
through their education and learn to be
an expert in something so let's get
those aligned
and then it worked its way into sort of
architecture and the interior design of
our new arena
what's the relationship for the crowd
with the team
how do we make it the first place that
any band wants to play in the world
but the last place any visiting team
wants to come play
well a lot of that's engineering where's
the student section how close to the
floor
what's the pitch is it standing room
only where is it standing room only
how can you be up in the cheaper seats
but still have a great experience in the
in the arena and not just be up in the
cheap seat
how can each area of the arena have a
different experience how do we make sure
we're bringing local retailers
food and beverage from austin into the
arena
things like that and then i'm also
working with austin fc the uh
our new our new football club soccer
club doing the same stuff
[Music]
oh by the way that little one i was
saying is so sweet a minute ago
halfway into me talking to you it had a
little late came back in overtime and
kind of
still got a little spicy
[Music]
okay
it's almost more of a jamaican jerk
fellow sweetness plus pepper in it
so matthew you've been so prolific in
film over the last 25 years it'd be
impossible to check
every box but we'll try to hit some
highlights here while you enjoy that
wing
i read that christopher nolan refused to
use green screen while making
interstellar what's the most
jaw-dropping set you saw actually
physically built for a scene in that
film
the test rack that again wasn't a green
screen i was dealing with a physical
tesseract and they were
i'd push off of it and i was on the pull
and they i was
80 feet above the ground swinging out
and they'd swing me back and we
rehearsed that quite a bit
um just to be done safely and looked
like zero gravity
but the test rack was a massive set that
was built so many other things you
think nolan does massive not when you
have like cooper falling through space
nolan's over on on like a there's a
tripod and there's a uh like a 12 foot
metal
uh pipe and i just strapped to that and
nolan's on the other side like a seesaw
just maneuvering it left and right he's
like he was like he was in film school
at university and that's and that's what
you could come up with
which was a more nerve-wracking on-set
experience
the on-stage thong scene and magic mike
are petting a live tiger in gold
ah that's a great question
i gotta go with magic mike because
somebody
somebody's hand when i was down there
went a little far
and i and i was like whoa this is about
it and i
snuck out i snuck out of there just in
time to come out as covered as i could
be
yeah now touching that damn tiger was a
different kind of buzz
i remember the heartbeat started racing
a little bit right there going
and then finally you've been in some of
the most beloved and highest grossing
rom-coms of all time yeah
what are the hallmarks of a good
romantic comedy like when they work
what makes them work yeah here's what it
is so listen i've thought a lot about
this because
we all know what's gonna happen in the
rom-com boy meets girl uh
some reason they break up boy chases
girl
hops on a moped or a bridge or somewhere
at the end
boy catches girl they get together then
we know that's the story
so what we got to do is say can we enjoy
that journey if we already know where
the story is going to end up
it's really so important about who the
two leads are here's the here's the
third thing
a good one has it lets the audience in
on a joke that one of the characters
doesn't know meaning if you for people
that enjoy how to lose a guy they would
enjoy it
when they the audience knew something
and i
my character knew something how i was
going to do k in a scene
when she didn't know it so they were in
on the joke oh we're going to get her
and then vice versa
when the audience was in on something
with her character where she was duping
me
the audience is having a whole lot of
fun going yeah yeah he's about to get
screwed over you know
that was a lot of the fun in the inner
activity that i think people enjoy about
rom-coms when they do enjoy them
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
got a molasses in it yeah and a little
more kick i think than the first three
yeah especially yeah comes in low and
longer
angry goat you'd figure an angry goat
without a little bit of kick yeah
so i know that you're a highwayman at
heart sometimes driving 1700 miles
on a whim and uninterrupted and i know
that in the early 2000s
you went from concert to baseball game
to wherever the wind took you on an
airstream
trailer you nicknamed canoe which part
of the country besides your beloved
texas did you find the friendliest
most down to help you with directions
type people
people like to say that like new yorkers
are you know gruff they don't want to
have
i've always found new yorkers to be
great at like helping with directing now
mind you
new yorkers aren't looking to see
looking for people to say hey can i help
you
no they're on the way doing something
but when you stop one uh and get their
attention i always found they get a
great direction
what i find most interesting about your
experience in particular as you were
doing this before there was like
ubiquitous internet and cell phone
coverage but you were really just
right there in the middle of your career
what's like the biggest
hot shot hollywood meeting that you ever
did at like a roadside rest stop or at a
campsite
yeah well see this this is what i would
do so if i had a big meeting and i did
have quite a few
[Music]
i would pick directors up in one place
and then
drive towards my destination dropped
them off at the
airport there and they'd fly out it was
always fun when that like i was headed
towards somewhere real cool and be like
oh i'll just come pick you up in vegas
as i'm pulling out
or you know um roger clemens is pitching
three nights from now i'm gonna i'm
headed up there to go watch him
pitch or king to leon somewhere playing
in the concert i'm actually heading
there in three days
hop in i'll drop you off and those are
all i hit
every single state besides north dakota
i got a feeling this is going to sneak
up a little bit
[Music]
okay let's see
[Music]
come on
[Music]
i like the setup and i got a feeling my
sentences are about to start getting
shorter
all right matthew wherever you're
current segment on our show called
explain that gram where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story yeah
first things first
you were on the sidelines at the 2006
rose ball game which many sports writers
call the greatest college football game
of all time
what is your lasting memory of that
vince young when he was playing
it was almost like 14 versus 11 and you
saw he did that national championship
game against usc
he had such poise in that game and was
having so much fun he was able to be so
present in that game that there was a
television timeout
in the third quarter when we were down
by about 10 points i don't know what it
was
they brought out three usc alumni on the
opposite end of the field to just sort
of be
the correct they were going to announce
their name and the crowd was going to go
great alumni they
achieved these things vince left the
huddle
ran down took off his helmet and shook
all their hands and met him and the ref
had to come home and go hey
gotta get back to the game we're
starting he's like oh yeah that's how
president that guy was
he knew we were going to win that game
he knew we were going to score on that
final drive when we did
beat usc he knew it arguably the best
one of those college players there's
ever been
when we had justin timberlake on the
show he said you have to get woody
harrelson on hot ones
you've described him as one of the last
wild men walking on earth and a longtime
friend what's going on in this picture
oh yeah
that's my brother right there so
obviously so you know this is uh
i would say this is probably uh
towards the a.m towards the beginning of
an a.m or maybe just into it a.m
[Laughter]
i love it and with there is you don't
hear it but there is uh
i think metallica's playing extremely
loudly
on major concert size speakers and lars
ulrich may be there just
outside of the frame and a few other
people
uh that that are in the rock and roll
business
and uh we are breaking a sweat on the
dan
on the dance floor even though there's
really not a dance floor um
we're breaking the sweat getting it out
right now shaking and shaking our tail
feather put some elbow grease into it
all right we're into this little guy
here heartbeat hot sauce thunder bay
ontario
i got a good friend from thunder bay
what's up repino
so some fans watching this might be
surprised to learn that you actually
teach a course at the university of
texas
called script to screen which follows
the process of making
a film from its original screenplay to
the movie that audiences
ultimately experience in theaters what
are some of the things that would
surprise people about the science behind
the magic of making a film
so after doing this for 28 years man i
really started to notice that
boy that product that we put on the
screen that you go to the theater and
see
or turn on your tube and see
very different from that original script
i read a year ago
or two years ago because i always
thought boy you see the written script
it has to be exactly that we have to
shoot exactly what's on the page
and no i learned to start learning that
from richard linklater my very first
film daisy confused
it's a collaboration there's one
director but you take inspiration and
ideas and
good ones from wherever they come from
whether it's the pa or whether it's the
actor or whoever
you take you look at the scene you're in
you take inspiration you work with what
you have
it became much more of a fun process to
direct and be a part of a movie like
that
what i said is look i want to take these
film students chronologically through
first script a second strip a third
script four strip shooting script
first edit and a final picture that you
see how you can
maybe run out of money and have to lose
one of the big action scenes that was
your favorite scene because you don't
have the money for it
uh and have to rewrite something else to
see how
oh someone like myself three lines in
their first movie
read the days confused script which
that's the script word script screen
doing in our
class right now at texas you'll see that
you'll see that i was in like
three scenes at three lines and you're
gonna be like whoa
he ended up being working for three
weeks he was all wooderson was all
through that movie
vice versa you may see someone who had a
big part and then you go see the movie
and you go
what happened to their part it's a bit
smaller now so you just see where all
the changes are so it's sort of that's
when i say putting the science behind
the magic of movie making
it's letting these different students
know the different ways that films
and movies and tv shows go from the
script to finally get the screen
[Music]
sauce hellfire
a little smoky in there yeah yeah
[Music]
so not since we had shia labeouf on the
show have i had a more pressing urge to
fact check the folklore surrounding a
guest as i do
right now is it true that the patron
saint of hot ones himself
guy fieri catered the after party of
your wedding fact
yeah man guy's great that guy reached
out um we hooked up probably
i don't know 10 years ago and remained
in contact um
he actually i introduced him when he got
his walk in the hall of fame here
recently just a few months ago
he also jammed and cooked burgers at my
50th birthday
yeah he's been a good bud man and uh
yeah he loves to get on some spice
okay that is this one okay number seven
just got sneaky and starts to get heated
outside the limes this is the first time
my lips
and things that this is one you don't
want to all right neither one we just
hit the moment where neither one of us
want to go
take a number one and touch our
you-know-what because we will now know
why it would be burning
okay very smart very smart and wait till
you try the next one
fact or fiction you once collected every
bad review that you could find about
yourself and then
read them obsessively as a way to like
improve as an actor
yeah i'm just learning to see if what i
thought i was doing was
how it was coming across i gathered up
all my bad reviews and it was a
it was a thick thick notebook and i
found some of people to be very
constructive i
found some other ones to be like oh this
person it didn't matter they already
wrote this review they didn't like it
they wrote this before they even came in
the movie
and then i found a lot of it to be very
funny um but funny in a good way
um and i got some good tips i learned
more from my bad reviews than i did for
my good ones
is it true that you lost a lawsuit
against a
skin cream company because you won most
attractive senior in your yearbook
so true the story is in the book i'll
give you the short version
my mom starts peddling this stuff called
oil of meat it's just door-to-door cells
and it's it's
just oh you put the sprinkle over your
face and it'll bring out the impurities
and whatever impurities you have it'll
bring them out that'll be gone forever
and you'll have beautiful glowing skin
for the rest of your life
i do it for three weeks straight i get
full blown acne unrecognizably swollen
head
i go to the dermatologist he's like what
do you put on your face i go here's this
oily mickey goes no
you're 15 years old and you it's
clogging your pores this is for people
40 years and older
well my dad got gosh damn we ought to
have that dude
young man should be young now unless
you'd be taking this stuff we're going
to sue that company
because he goes to his is a lawyer we
think jerry is like oh we can get 35 to
50
000 this is emotionally stressed matthew
were you emotionally distressed during
this time like oh yes sir
was your confidence slower oh yes sir
was it going as well with the girls no
sir oh this is emotional stress we can
get 50 grand well as you know lawsuits
take a while so a year and a half go by
i'm now in the deposition and the
defense attorney is talking to me
and he starts off he goes this must have
been so
emotionally distressed with you matthew
and i'm sitting there going jeez he's
giving me a softball i'm knocking this
out apartment yes it was but i'm sitting
there going chi-ching
all of a sudden he pulls that from the
table that's your book
earmarked slides it over in front of me
turns it around
opens it up and it was a picture of me
from that year my senior year i had one
most handsome
my dad was like gosh damn you buddy he
goes we were going to make
fifty thousand dollars you gotta go off
and win most handsome come on man
that's great so yeah we lost we like we
like those suits we just we're not very
good at picking the right litigations
not them
the bomb beyond insanity with the
caution
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you start to notice that these get to be
a little less about taste
and they start to go right to your
tonsils a little bit
and i don't know if it matters what the
hell we were putting them on
i think yeah okay
number eight just reminded me that yeah
you don't wanna
you don't wanna buy a filet mignon or a
ribeye to put this on you might as well
get that
[Music]
here we go so one of my favorite matthew
mcconaughey quotes is
to understand me you need to understand
texan logic
and i'm not sure how aware of this you
are these homespun mcconaughey-isms
they've inspired been shared and meme to
a point that they're almost their own
internet language so
in order to better understand i'd like
to just bounce a few off of you
and get an interpretation from the man
himself
no matter who you're in bed with you're
only sleeping with one person
yourself fact all right think about it
no matter who's next to you the only one
person's leaving on your pillow one
person you can't get rid of
us better shake hands try and get along
next
on the best advice that you've ever
received i've had thousands of crises in
my life
and most of them never happened yep
don't do false drama
real drama's coming let it slide a lot
of times at any crisis if we just don't
give it credit
it's important to realize that fame is a
dance
and i'd like to think i've got my dance
down better now
like my favorite fans are usually the
dave's fans that we're walking down the
street i'm walking one way they're
walking the other
and that guy say man you got a joint
and i'll hear it and i go be like cooler
if you did
and we both cackle and we never even
looked at each other and just cackle
through the streets and then other
people in the street start laughing too
that's my favorite thing
[Music]
hey did you write as big a bite as i did
now
that's very serious so are the next two
be very careful be very careful
so this next one is the chipotle express
[Music]
[ __ ] button
[Music]
ah
very earthy yeah earthy earthy sound
earthy be nice right now
so recently it was announced that you'd
be voicing hank the cow dog in a podcast
adaptation of the classic children's
book series
hank the cow dog was apparently a big
part of the childhood of a lot of people
that work here on first we feast
what can you tell the people about
legendary cowboy storyteller john r
erickson well i got turned on hank a cow
dog by jeff nichols the director of mud
so he brought them to me a couple years
ago and turned me on to him so i
listened to a lot of the series so what
you got is hank the cow dog this
cow dog whose head haunts you on the
ranch and you know thinks he's god gifts
of ranching and
isn't always right tells out these tall
stories and
shares a few lessons along the way and
you get to laugh at him
being the uh sort of hero that he
becomes in very funny ways
as well we're getting them running to
different school programs where the
students and young kids are learning the
lessons
of hank the cal dog and the ranch hand
stories in the classroom
[Music]
how about that i got that out
ah
this last one huh last tab
dude huh
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah big i'm bad i'm okay matthew
mcconaughey yeah here we are at the end
of our extremely spicy feast
and we've covered a lot of ground from
your new book green lights
to the movies that you've made and we've
soaked up a lot of wisdom along the way
but i want to close by talking about
your spiritual side
i know it's very important to you and to
focus it this 2008 quote
i want to be reincarnated as a jaguar
they're the coolest animals in the world
do you remember how you first
experienced a profound connection with
the jaguar
and why do you want to live like one
as one in another life anybody think i
might have been hanging out with woody
when i said that one
um jaguars has always been you've always
been my favorite animal i don't know why
i hunted down jaguar in the in the in
the jungles of peru and down into the
down the odobama river on the amazon and
the day tracks and night tracks
never touched him until i got to gold
the movie but did you
track one oh check this out kept the uh
jaguar gold
i noticed on the call sheet it happened
to be the last scene in the movie
i'm a producer on the movie but i go
this is a very smart scheduling
but does anyone want to talk about why
this is the last
seen in the movie like well if something
does happen
we'll have it in the camera in the movie
that's good scheduling
here we go well you know what i'm happy
that you survived that scene and i'm
happy that you survived today's meal and
look at you matthew mcconaughey
working your way through the wings of
death and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera or possibly a camera b if
you've set one up
let the people know what you have going
on in your life what i got going on in
my life gang is i'm trying to
make it through this whole code thing
like the rest of it's trying to keep it
pulsed on with the smart things to do i
hope you're wearing a mask out there
because i'm ready to party again too
like you are the best way we can do that
is wear one when we get out in public
what have i been doing right now i'm on
a tour gonna sell my favorite piece of
art i've ever put out called green life
it's a book i wrote
as you heard from sean i went away 52
days solitary confinement came out of
the desert with something i'm really
honored with
it's funny it's got some wisdom bombs
hopefully it's going to help everyone go
want to have a good lap to maybe learn a
little something get inspired
but also what green lights are about man
it's about turning them on and turning
some yeses on in our own life
and other lives hopefully we can all we
can go away from the book and
going in our life being more green
lighters ourselves man and creates more
opportunities for ourselves
and others and that sir is a
honey hole
[Music]
let's keep rocking catch more of these
enjoyed it sean see you next time thanks
for having me
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's video
and i have very exciting news
the newest member of the last dab family
is finally here
say hello to apollo the last dab
apollo here's my 30 second review for
what it's worth
this is the hottest last dab sauce that
we've ever made
by a lot i'm actually not even sure if
that's a selling point
but it's just fair warning the last dab
apollo it has that deep
rich complex flavor profile that
smokinet is known for
deep heavy diesel pepper big
extreme heat you don't have to if you
don't want to but if you want to
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the last ab apollo
around here we call it the gold label